first of all what do I think personally
I think my other panelists might
disagree is capitalism the highest form
I hope not but first of all
we will need to be in a situation where
basically we have abolished scarcity
until we have that as Trotsky
brilliantly put it in the revolution
betrayed when you have shortages cues
form then a policeman is called to keep
order he never fails to help himself
first
so and I I think that I ignored the
problem when I chose to LEAP into
Marxism I knew already as a PhD in
economics who really believed in in it
also that scarcity was not going to be
abolished easily and with the new things
we have seen that Frank Brody things
haven't happened the productivity gains
uh we have so many more things we want
all over the world
and we are not of course we could want
less I am happy I no longer want plastic
bags and I'm perfectly willing to have a
cloth bag I carry around and it doesn't
have to have a label now but the point
is that
um we can want somewhat less and maybe
that's one of the things we will get out
of this long period of deleveraging that
we will learn to live with less and with
more Leisure which we didn't learn to do
and we will have there are some positive
sides to it but uh it will be not in our
lifetimes and I don't think in your
children's lifetimes not even the
youngest people in the room but someday
I hope that many things will be again as
Trotsky said like a well-mannered
boarding house but I personally as
somebody who tends in a well-mounted
boarding house to take the eggs I like
first I have to be careful and think yes
first there have to be enough eggs for
everybody
um and that's the I don't want to my
answer to the other is do we even live
under capitalism that is a definitional
question and I don't think that it is
relevant unless you are a Marxist
I want to know if I want to know if it's
good or not first then we can work out
what it is
and again
social democracy now I think social
democracy has to decide what it's doing
that one of the problems was that what I
call social democracy and what I came to
next decided instead to buy into the
bubble and the Boom
and it needs to find its way back and I
hope that people like Tristram will be
part of that because they went from the
right of me to the the left of me to the
right of me in a whiz and many of you
others may have felt that I think there
is a role for government in the banks
for example I'll I'll think I'll stop
okay thanks dude
yes I I think that you can blame social
democracy for many many bad things but
not for uh causing the problems because
the interesting thing is that no matter
what the government is whether it's a
Reagan that government or a Christian
Democratic LED government in Germany or
a social democratic government in France
or in England
we see a similar pattern of relying more
and more on the credit mechanism we see
a situation around the Reagan and
Thatcher you had the securitization of
the credit system on the Reagan in the
earlier period you have actually an
increase in state expenditure for a
certain Imperial time but State
expenditure not necessarily for welfare
payments but for armaments and for other
areas so I think it's important to
realize that there is no government in
the western capitalist world that didn't
buy into this policy whose consequences
we're not paying for I haven't sort of
come across any of that in the 70s and
the 80s and the early 90s I think that
the really important thing for us to to
remember here is that the state can be
used for all kinds of reasons at the
moment we have the wrong balance a state
ought to be providing resources for
productive Investments like the way that
labor did for the channel tunnel in the
70s or the way that the French have done
high-speed trains but instead of doing
that we're spending State expenditure on
transfer payments in a way that has got
no productive operative what kind of
consequences and I think we do need to
have a very serious discussion of the
balance between private capital and the
state but at the moment all the
political parties are avoiding
and George quickly very quickly I mean
so we just want to endorse you know
pretty much everything that Judas said
I'm not going to repeat it I thought it
was eloquently put they as an account
sorry it's a bit nerdy right but that's
kind of what I do
um but the the standard text now about
what do we know about financial crises
and why do they happen and how well how
do they behave and how do you get over
them is now a a book by two American
economists by called rogoff and
Reinhardt it's called Eight centuries of
financial crises hey sorry you know
eight centuries of financial crises This
Time It's Different I.E never is
different and I think you know Frank's
point which is that it didn't really
matter what side of political system it
was whether it was social democracy
whether it was free market whether it
was you know whatever it was I mean
everybody suffered from the same problem
and the problem is uh well the problem
is just deregulation in my opinion that
actually the the idea about that you
could free up those Animal Spirits in
finance and expect human behavior to
control itself I mean it's a human
problem uh and it's something that is
you know it's a Serial human problem
that goes back to the days of Rome and
even before
um it's not a uniquely capitalistic
problem it's exaggerated by capitalism
uh because of the nature of it but I
think that the idea that you uh I mean
there as I said before there are lots of
interesting ideas about you know whether
it's you know Mutual Societies or you
know cooperatives uh but you know
handing kind of having State Banks the
Chinese Banks were mentioned before the
Chinese banks are insolvent so you know
and the only way that they stay in
business is because of because they get
continuously bankrolled by the state
that's not the answer either okay
quickly Robin
it is absolutely the answer I think one
of the marvelous things about the crisis
is we suddenly realize
money which used to be that great thing
that there was such a huge lack of that
actually governments can just country it
into existence and can endow other
institutions with it so instead of using
them using it to endow commercial Banks
I I would rather think the network of
social funds that would be a much more
creative way to use it and I think it
sort of provides some of the answer to
the question can we do better I think if
we look at the world there's too much
misery far too much and I think it'd be
wrong for Judith to imply that we can
sort of live with that and imagine the
market will spontaneously solve it the
market hasn't solved it so I think we've
got to tackle it deliberately I'm just
back from Brazil and Ecuador and I can
say those countries have seen inequality
sharply reduced in the last 10 years
because there are radical social
democratic governments that haven't
given up the ghost as sadly most
European social Democrats have done and
have taken really Stern steps to spread
economic initiative to show that there
is such a thing as public
entrepreneurialism that can tackle
problems and get the economy moving